hubert est il le seul à vouloir changer
les règles hubert x est un service qui
découle de l'application hubert est
considérée comme une concurrence
déloyale par des chauffeurs de taxi et
denis coderre n'en veut plus à montréal
tonnes questions de transport une égale
hubert dès qu'il s'agit là de
covoiturage et voudrait que de nouvelles
règles soient édictées pour encadrer ce
secteur et hubert n'est pas le seul à
vouloir changer les règles ypres attaque
si une compagnie de taxis montréalaise
qui a aussi une application veut
notamment que les chauffeurs de taxi
puisse avoir de la publicité à
l'intérieur comme à l'extérieur de leur
auto ce qui n'est toujours pas permis
aujourd'hui
xpand le fonds d'investissement du
dragon alexandre taillefer veut lancer
sous peu une compagnie de taxis
électriques
xpand voudrait que les règles entourant
l'achat de permis taxis soit assouplie
hubert hypra xpand sont maintenant
inscrits au registre des lobbyistes du
québec